foreign
okay so again the drill
is uh we put him in a precarious base
right because he we don't he doesn't
have a break a basic support going
forward
uh and we have a very slow moving Arc
here going up okay what I mean by that
is this is on a circumference due to the
ball and socket joint okay
and so this makes this a very easy drill
to understand what matching young values
are again remember cosmologically
when I match young values the Universe
goes I don't see two things and it
treats it as one and the observable uh
sensation is an adhesion or an increase
of friction between those two things
because
homeostasis wants to keep them one thing
and so there's a resistance to them
becoming an apartment okay so uh what
I'm going to do my stance does not
matter but and actually you don't really
need much ground path here because he is
so precariously based and this movement
is so slow uh to what he's doing okay
but try to work with the idea that
you're going to let his yaw movement go
but here I'm into it so I'm not going to
push it down because that's going to
ground him and he's bigger than me uh
and he'll push me off of him okay
instead I will let him uh come up and I
match that young movement and then I
just pull them off that precarious face
okay
it's like yeah he goes
I'm just pulling them off
okay you see I want you to I don't
really care where you put your hands but
try not to hook on things try not to
hook on things okay let the energy do it
do its own thing okay as you get uh some
sense of what that feels like that and
that's what I really want out of you is
that you generate the feeling in you and
you start to match that feeling okay so
he goes and I match that feeling
uh once you have that feeling I'd like
for you to try with even less it's not
important how much I touch or where I
touch so you can you can touch with one
finger and he's going and you'll be able
to pull that off okay
um do you see that so I tried I do it
here but with flat Palms okay and then
later maybe maybe you want to try with
two fingers or maybe do with one finger
and you pull it off so if I don't know
if the camera wants to come here you and
you could feel that there's like a
friction such that his skin moves do you
see that okay so go back down
so he goes up and then I'm just gonna
move to see how his Skin's moving okay
and he keeps going and I will pull that
off okay
um
you kind of you don't you don't need
your base at all because you can ground
after all one base go ahead and you'll
pull that off
okay so try it let's try those three
things again one
two or two and then
three let's see what we get then okay
let's try it
all right so if you if you guys should
recognize that this is pretty slippery
for me okay uh ground Vector vectoring
doesn't have anything to do with how
sticky
um and the reason you want to understand
that is
and why I describe it as matching young
values as opposed to pulling on skin or
working faster or anything like that
is that yin and yang are relative okay
so
um the more I release
the higher his young value is to what
I'm doing
you guys get that okay so if this looks
like it's very minor
right but I can make it more Minor by
being very relaxed
and you see that his skin right at the
beginning did you see that right so
again my hand is very light I'm very
relaxed
psychologically spiritually I have
released everything and so as I go we're
already at that sticky part do you see
you know and I could push it back even
okay you can move it because there's
always yawn
I don't need that to happen
as I'm relaxed I can make his young
value relatively increase and you could
get the effect okay do you guys
understand that so as you're trying all
these drills you want to try to release
more and you could do different you
could do all those stuff without him
having to push
hugely into what you're doing you see
that at the at at touch
you could already do that you see
you get that okay uh likewise I don't
know if it's possible
but here
um it it looks like because he's going
up against my hand that
um
that that is somehow mechanically
responsible for what we're seeing again
I do acknowledge that we've set him up
like this because it's easier to get the
feeling okay uh and we have to have the
feeling in order to keep trying to find
that feeling and then develop that skill
uh but in terms of energy there should
be no reason why I have to be here
you understand I I can be here in front
and he goes to to lift his arm again if
I'm too light he'll slide off if I'm too
heavy it's pushing me you see that but I
can that is Young and he goes and I can
start pulling that thing
from not being on top of it
got it okay in order to do that I have
to be able to make whatever his Yong is
quite relatively High which I Do by
releasing my
my values okay you got that okay so just
for uh shits and giggles here
um well you I want you to try to get him
early or maybe with no no uh no feeling
no movement of bizarre and then try the
one where you're in front and see if you
could get
you understand how it's you happening
the same way
I I know maybe we can't do it but do you
understand in terms of the yin yang
Theory
his arm is going up right
and I will match that value and the
universe will go that's one thing and as
I pull my one thing here he gets kind of
stuck to it you guys see that okay all
right just for shits and giggles trial
but use that other drill uh quite
frequently like you guys show up and
just try the other drill and then keep
trying to release release again
spiritually psychologically emotionally
right relax the tension in the fear
locations of your body and try to do the
same feeling keeping the feeling don't
try to move him
you already know you can move them try
to keep the feeling that was there when
he moved and now that's what you try
again over and over okay all right let's
try this one for shits and giggles